hey what's going on is filburn it's time
for the Monday morning podcast September
10th 2018 how's it going how are ya how
are ya I am back from a whirlwind tour
[ __ ] crazy weekend I'm actually
sitting here podcasting in front of the
TV which I know a lot of you don't like
simply the [ __ ] Steelers and Browns
had a tie Wow Jesus Christ one that this
is exact reason why you don't like it
this is the exact [ __ ] reason cuz I
get distracted I haven't seen a [ __ ]
tie since like they've had overtime I
don't really I don't recall 1 0 0 & 1
the Pittsburgh Steelers and the
Cleveland Browns how about that anyways
yeah I'm sitting there I got the Red Sox
game on in the background the Houston
Astros are trying to become the second
team this season to sweep the Red Sox
well Boston is trying to go two for two
today against the city of Houston
alright now we already done kick the
[ __ ] out you [ __ ] football team now
we're try them with your baseball team
I'll be honest with you uh I thought the
Patriots looks good for the first two
and a half quarters special teams was
letting up more yards than I would like
then you would like Bill you as a what a
football coach you as a comedian a [ __ ]
joke telling [ __ ] jackass who decided
to [ __ ] record a game and
fast-forward through the commercials
yeah bill what did you see on your game
film fair enough fair enough you know
there's always room for criticism Who am
I to sit here and act like I'm above it
yeah I thought I was very impressed with
our pass rush I was very impressed with
our ability to contain what's his name
Watson there I thought he was going to
be a nightmare I also thought he might
have been a little gun-shy a
about running because he is coming back
from a knee injury so I thought when he
ran when he had to but I was impressed
with him staying in the pocket I liked
the new left guard we got their left
tackle I should say taking over for Nate
Soldier solder what do you say his name
it's only there for [ __ ] 20 years now
he's playing with the Giants Brown
whoever that guy was he was keeping all
those beasts up front four of the Texans
well they got clowny they got JJ Watts
and then they got some other guy like
maniac or something like that like his
name is literally like it's like psycho
or maniac or something like that not a
nickname the name he was born with as a
baby oh look at that little cute baby
what's its name
Clarence maniac you want to have a
playdate no I don't why are my [ __ ]
headphones [ __ ] goddamn these [ __ ]
cheap-ass [ __ ] things I swear to god
I just can't win cannot [ __ ] win what
is going on now this is all brand new
[ __ ] I got all brand new [ __ ] here
people speaking of which if you want to
[ __ ] if you want to a couple things
I'm selling I just bought a new mixer my
old one works fine but I'm getting back
to doing these uninformed with Joe
DeRosa which is gonna be up on my
patreon page coming up here in November
we're gonna tape some episodes get a
little in the can and that type of [ __ ]
and some other stuff so I do get a mixer
where I could actually have enough
microphones for more than two people so
I have a mixer with the cords and all of
that [ __ ] if you want to start your own
podcast if you want to open up your
little podcast shop across the street
and compete with me let me know I'll
figure it out because I already started
dean del rey selling some [ __ ] I got a
drum kit that I'm selling all right I'll
get all the information
I'll have it posted on my [ __ ]
Twitter site I'm selling this one of
those sonar like travel kits you know
it's kind of like the Questlove won the
what is it whatever that one that he
does with a little [ __ ] 18-inch bass
drum it's the same thing but it's a Sona
and [ __ ] beautiful I just don't have
the room for it anymore
I got a I made a little drum room in my
garage so I don't have to have a studio
space for my drum so and I brought the
big boy kit home and I got that little
one which [ __ ] sounds great by the
way and I also have the the [ __ ] pads
there where it's silent you know what I
mean
where it doesn't it doesn't you know the
mesh ones or the real ones
I got it tuned up nice my buddy tuned it
up I should say after I kind of [ __ ]
it up a little bit but whatever that's
what has come down to people this is the
new me okay I am getting rid of [ __ ] and
right now you know what my whole [ __ ]
day my headphones aren't working right
now I have no [ __ ] idea if you can
all I'm doing is just looking at the
[ __ ] mixer I know that you can hear
me I haven't been able to contain home I
went to watch the [ __ ] Patriots game
my wife angel that she is taped the game
for me and then I'm sitting here
watching it and it the thing just like
it starts [ __ ] up then I gotta hit
pause I gotta shut it off I got to turn
it back on it was doing like one of
those [ __ ] things and it started off
what was doing it every couple of
minutes then once a minute oh you [ __ ]
foul ball foul ball was that fair foul
father all right sorry
um it's 2 to 1 red sucks by the way
Astros are up he just hit one down by
the pesky pole it went foul anyways so
then it started doing it like every 30
seconds and it was like every eight
[ __ ] seconds and I was loved and
watching the game Tony Romo I'm calling
it right now Tony Romo if he [ __ ]
keeps doing this [ __ ] he's going to be a
Hall of Fame broadcaster I have never
learned more [ __ ] about football I don't
think maybe since I'm going back maybe
they like John Madden the way the guys
breaking down all of this stuff and it
has always been all these coaches and
all this [ __ ] tried to do it somehow the
way Tony Romo does it it's like you get
it he does
in real-time it's [ __ ] amazing so I
was enjoying that so you know how the
world works out what are you enjoying
something well let's [ __ ] up the
recording of it so that's what ended up
happening and you know what it's funny
but my [ __ ] is if I sit up and I'm
uncomfortable they work perfect but if I
lean back and I'm comfortable I swear to
god dude I don't know what the [ __ ] I
think I said
did I kill Tesla and another [ __ ]
life is that what I did and this is my
[ __ ] punishment this is literally all
brand new [ __ ] I swear to God I don't
know what the [ __ ] I did I kick Edison
in the balls during a previous light
well he's a [ __ ] thief anyways right
I guess where you going unbelievable and
this is the [ __ ] right my wife never
flips out about [ __ ] like this you know
why cuz it never happens to her cuz she
buys new [ __ ] and it works my wife will
like lose her cell phone in Grand
Central Station and then I'll call it
and then just be some guy yeah yes I
have it
no no I'll bring it to you right
I lose my cell phone that's [ __ ] it
over cold case file no leads no nothing
that [ __ ] is gone alright so it's
better over here a little better over
here a little better now this [ __ ]
thing is hanging off it this whole
[ __ ] podcast is just gonna be me
bitching about this [ __ ] wire that I
just bought now it's off now it's off
now it's on oh I see what happens when
there's a little bit of weight and it's
hanging down oh it can't handle that
kanya can't [ __ ] handle a little bit
of [ __ ] weight is that what it is I
just figured what out what it is oh we
got a quitter here everybody my mixer
just fell off the [ __ ] table
just going off the rails here
why do I try to make my life easier it
doesn't work out so anyways I uh can I
lean back and in the old man put his
[ __ ] back up against the couch hello
test oh there we go there we go alright
so I'm back
well you just dumb it what you just saw
that was why my wife is sick of living
with me you know everything's a [ __ ]
conspiracy theory with me
I really wish when those sort of
challenging moments and in the first
world country as a blue-eyed white male
that was actually a challenging moment
for me as people are there are like
literally Sling war-torn [ __ ]
countries having god-knows-what done to
them right if there is a God and he's
looking down right now and he hears all
this screaming and yelling and [ __ ]
about stuff that's going on and he finds
out what's this what's this poor soul
screaming about right after he looks at
the horrors a war and he's gonna just
see some bald 50 year old [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing a podcast by himself yelling about
a microphone cord he's just gonna look
down and it is a he by the way all right
[ __ ] all this feminist [ __ ] well now
they turning everything around you know
[ __ ] this you know it's gotta be
something has to still be a guy right
why not God oh why do I love being an
[ __ ] I just I enjoy it
I'm sorry I do alright he's gonna be
looking down and be like who is that I
made that alright do me a favor
when he passes yet give him the tell him
to take the down escalator um I don't
know where I'm gonna go when I die I
can't we think about that [ __ ] I watched
that Mister Rogers won't you be my
neighbor did you [ __ ] see that you
guys watch that thing whatever you call
it their documentary I have never felt
like such a piece of [ __ ] in my life
after watching that
he's definitely [ __ ] weird though man
he is so [ __ ] weird
you know says the guy by himself losing
his [ __ ] talking into a microphone
I had them nerve to say that this guy's
weird but I yeah
take it easy end of the inning gun down
sorry anyways I I watched that
documentary and Fred Rogers Mike I said
if this if if there is a God and
Christians are right and God had his son
without having sex with a virgin Jesus I
mean just how do you even say it out
loud and still believe it I mean it's
just clearly written by guys who don't
want sloppy seconds you know so then
they gotta have to have like that like
she's a virgin
no one ever banged it before so she
doesn't know what good sex is she
doesn't know what a big dick is now I
could feel comfortable to mount this
person I mean he said it's that it was
that the underlying theme of all of that
huh I hate look at that that's sort of a
feminist look at it isn't it I don't
know what sorry I apologize to everybody
south of [ __ ] Washington DC the
mason-dixon line there do you guys know
the first you know the Gettysburg
Address yeah I had no [ __ ] idea where
that was in the first [ __ ] battle of
the Civil War I thought it was like you
know somewhere in the a sec they were in
Big Ten country they were in [ __ ]
Pennsylvania I had no idea we never
would get that far we always start with
those [ __ ] three ships the Nina the
Pinta and the Santa Maria they came oh
they somehow they came over after
Columbus right Columbus came over to
like I don't like Cuba
well the Bahamas Haiti he was down
around there right and then the Nina the
Pinta and the Santa Maria they all came
over together right sort of the first
Carnival Cruise it's kind of like that
without you know a workout room and
scurvy and [ __ ] like that right big belt
buckles
they must had a credible neck muscles
back then huh a big [ __ ] hat with
that belt on they're looking down at
your soggy [ __ ] boots bringing your
head back up anyways they were all
trapped easy the coach used to come off
slide right off their [ __ ]
non-existent shoulders so anyways we
would start with that [ __ ] and then we
would maybe get to the war of 1812 never
[ __ ] with the Civil War as far as
where I went to school we never [ __ ]
with it it was just our country fighting
each other why would that be of interest
to anybody you know maybe that was just
northerners being cool you know ain't
not talkin [ __ ] after winning yeah we
don't need to teach him that we won
right a bit down south a what was
talking about it probably saying that we
cheated you know like people hate the
Patriots say we under inflated our
[ __ ] cannon balls or whatever the [ __ ]
they're gonna say you know anyways let
me uh somebody just sent me a text at
Aaron Rodgers get hurt please tell me I
[ __ ] hate when that happens
Roger is done he grabbed that knee so
fast it's bad oh no oh Jesus Christ I
[ __ ] hate you it's just there's
nothing worse than that you know what I
mean I'm gonna tell you something if
you're a Vikings fan or a Bears fan and
you're psyched that that happened you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I never
rooted for Derek Jeter to get hurt or in
that [ __ ] you wanted you want to play
him when the when you want to beat him
with that best Wow
does that change the NFC my buddy who
actually knows something about football
was was picking them to go to the Super
Bowl Wow you know what that reminds me
of remember that year one
jets were favored it was like the first
game of the season
Testaverde you know blew out his
Achilles and uh who cried it wasn't
Terrell Owens it was the guy from USC
Wow Jesus Christ just give me the damn
ball
when did wide the wide receiver position
become the diva position he used to
always be the quarterback he was the guy
always walking around with the big
inflated [ __ ] ego and somewhere in
the last like 15 20 years like all the
emotional meltdowns come from the guys
who like catch the balls you know that's
my quarterback just give me the damn
ball oh Jesus Christ
anyways so I worked up in a Thunder
Valley slender Valley [ __ ] California
the the farthest north I have been in
Sacramento all right I was I landed in
Sacramento was a 30 minute drive from
this guy fortunately he took like the
back roads which was really cool so he
went by all these these farms and I
actually for the first time saw an
almond tree III thought nuts came from
the ground you know cuz I always you
know I was go to baseball whenever I go
to a baseball game they give you the
ones that they feed to the elephants
those are like the [ __ ] you know the
Budweiser of peanuts almonds are sort of
like the Blue Moon you know a little
more [ __ ] crafty beer kind of snobby
right but those those elephant ones they
always seem like that dirty take I
didn't know that nuts came on trees I'm
probably making an ass of myself right
now either they all do or that's the one
that does or whatever but I know there's
a lot of you right now just racing to
look up this information so then you can
tell me how dumb I am
or maybe you [ __ ] know that you know
you don't know
grow one you don't know when to pick it
you just know where it comes from right
so now all of a sudden I'm the biggest
[ __ ] ever is is that what happened no
bill you're the biggest [ __ ] ever
because you just had a meltdown about a
[ __ ] wire fair enough fair enough
Jesus Christ the buccaneers and saints
forty eight to forty I got to tell you
before it's all said and done
Drew Brees is gonna throw for more
[ __ ] everything than anybody unless
Tom Brady keeps playing because I don't
think Drew Brees is doing that drew
versus time Tom Brady versus time like
that [ __ ] like today they would actually
they said he was the oldest quarterback
to throw a touchdown in the first game
of the year other than George Blanda
who's the Gordie [ __ ] howl of
football as far as how long he played
and in Warren Moon who I didn't know I
didn't know he played that late I know
he spent most at least half his career
up in the CFL maybe that's why he didn't
seem like he was that old because by the
time he came in the league he was
already like eight years in the CFL
anyways why do I have the [ __ ] TV on
why do I give a [ __ ] should I hit pause
let me hit pause you know at the end of
the day I have a job here to do and it's
too goddamn it is to make you people
laugh well you know what it's a new TV
and I don't know how to do it does this
do it oh my god it did it I hit the
pause button and it paused [ __ ] that I'm
in play I still have that thing you
remember the old days when you paused
you a flat screen and then it just
burned in there whatever the [ __ ] you
were looking at all right look the other
way okay so I watched won't you be my
neighbor and then I also watched
Chappaquiddick you got a check both both
those movies out were incredible and any
other may stay on track here so we took
the the back roads
up to this casino up there Thunder Bay
not Thunder Bay sorry Thunder Valley and
uh you know every once in a while I'll
actually watch the news and whenever I
watch the news it always puts me into a
panic and makes me feel like I should
live in the middle of nowhere next to a
lake with a bunch of guns you know and I
know there's a lot of people in the
cities probably think that stuff okay
well here's the deal the only way to
live in the middle of nowhere is if you
grew up in the middle of nowhere because
then you know how to live out there
right you came from a family that it
that taught you how to hunt and all of
that [ __ ] you know what I mean I'm too
[ __ ] old for that I got to go the
Snake Plissken route and try to stay in
you know in a [ __ ] City you know I
think I'm gonna join the people that
live underground in the sewers cuz it's
gonna be so [ __ ] hot you know the
redheads all less redheads we're gonna
end up underground we're gonna be coming
up like a bunch of filthy Malachi's so
you guys better sharpen your [ __ ]
swords or whatever the hell you're gonna
have once you run out of bullets that's
gonna be the thing when you run out of
[ __ ] bullets then it'll be swords and
just clubs and it's good it's gonna
become [ __ ] Braveheart you know but
not if we were all like Fred Rogers he'd
be just sitting there in the middle of
it it's such a good feeling to know
you're alive and when you crawl up out
of that manhole I would appreciate it if
you what the [ __ ] just happened he got
all of that one how did it go from two
other here three run [ __ ] homer I
don't you know who did it
very nice
that's right Houston how does it feel to
be owned Chilean people do that [ __ ] the
big story here is that the Houston
Astros are gonna take two out of three
which this is a series now this is one
of these wants that I pay attention to
because we're gonna run into these
sumbitches come October so I want to see
how we match up my branded Chris sales
not in there I don't know if price
pitched I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on so anyways we get up there at a
Thunder Valley and it is literally a
[ __ ] casino just surrounded by
farmland and the gig it's this giant
stage just like out in the parking lot
and if nobody's covered right if there
was any sort of rain I was joking like
everybody would just [ __ ] leave and I
would be contractually obligated to do
an hour in front of a bunch of plastic
wet folding chairs but I got to tell you
it's one of my favorite gigs I've had in
a long time it was amazing the sky was
beautiful the only thing that was weird
was like when motorcycles would go by I
had to like stop doing my act like I was
literally getting like heckled by those
things I was joking about how those
people up there they probably don't wear
helmets you know what I mean anytime you
have a problem you just drive off into a
bunch of snow peas those things are
probably nice and soft slow you down and
then after that I I woke up the next
morning at like something ridiculous I
want to say it was 4 a.m. 4 a.m. and
then I had to get on a 6:00 a.m. flight
something like that I can't even [ __ ]
remember fly to Salt Lake City and from
Salt Lake City go to Toronto fort if the
Toronto International Film Festival his
old freckles is in a movie called the
front runner directed by Jason Reitman
starring Hugh Jackman and I just I saw
it for the first time anyways let me
tell you the whole [ __ ] story
so I one of my favorite things I've seen
in an airport standing in line right
trying to find something healthy but you
can't really do and this guy in front of
me he orders two bagels and he goes can
you put butter on it can you put want
two bagels with butter on it and he's
like already on his tiptoes like over
the counter and he's tall enough to see
over the counter so it's like what he's
one of these [ __ ] guys like when you
prepare his food he has all these
[ __ ] instructions and he's on his
tiptoes watching you do it and
immediately I'm just like god bless
the [ __ ] woman or man romantically
linked to this [ __ ] lunatic right so
he's on he's on his tiptoes that yeah
he's on his [ __ ] tiptoes watching
this lady she sticks it in the little
[ __ ] conveyor belt piece of [ __ ]
toaster and it comes out she's put into
two guys girl can you put Keith with the
butter on it ma'am could you just put
the bun she goes what she goes can you
put the butter on she goes yes she goes
the butters over there he goes no I was
just hoping that you could put butter on
it while it's still hot so to like melt
Kent can you do that can you just put
butter on it while it's still hot and
then close it up can you do that for me
she just looks at him and goes no now I
know I've always made fun of I hate
those [ __ ] places where all of a
sudden you got to finish making the
sandwich like you worked there for free
but just the way she just told the guy
no and he was already annoying me the
way he was up on his [ __ ] tiptoes
like what the [ __ ] you didn't order like
a I'm trying to think of something fancy
you ordered a [ __ ] bagel she's gonna
toast the thing she's gonna stick it in
a bag you're gonna pay for it then
you're gonna go over to the condiments
I'm trying to find something that wasn't
sneezed on you know how it's going down
so I laughed and she looked at me and
gave me like half a smile she's like
what do you want I'm just like I'll take
one of those ham and cheese sandwiches
you know you know what do anything to it
oh that was great watching that guy get
shut down
why it's like he ever see a little
spoiled [ __ ] brat kid crying
you know because he wants something is
there anything better watching a parent
not cave and then the kid doesn't get it
I file it for that moment he when the
kid cries and cries and cries and then
the parents end up just giving it to him
I always makes me just want to like trip
him isn't that stupid
I don't obviously I'm just saying you
know something I do think about I'm not
proud of it we all have our flaws
occasionally yes I see I see no I see a
kid get something after crying and makes
me want to trip him it's stupid because
the kid doesn't have the emotional
maturity to express himself right wanna
help Fred Rogers would have handled that
if he didn't want him to have it why are
you crying
well you can't have oh my god what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is this bug god bless
her there's a woman there she's wearing
a Houston Astros fan she's wearing like
one of those you know they make the
number-one finger out of she's got a
giant orange Astros hat like to the
point you're blocking people's view
behind you those are the things it's
because of hats like that and people
like that that wear amid games that's
one of the reasons why like things like
flamethrowers are not legal to the
general public because that's the kind
of thing when you sit there for nine
[ __ ] innings all right and that
self-centered [ __ ] won't take the
[ __ ] thing off that's one of the
things if you had like a handheld I'm
not saying you'd burn her but you'd like
the Hat on fire and God knows what
that's made out of and it might you know
touch somebody else's [ __ ] hat and
then they're on fire and you're like but
no no I just wanted to set her on fire
I'm sorry sir my bad my bad
would you like me to drive you to the
burn unit no most of your ear is still
attached
anyway so then I flew up to Canada and I
checked like 9 million times that I had
my passport cuz that's one of the things
I always you know the first half of my
career you could just go to Canada like
you're going to your friend's house you
didn't need a passport you know and then
after 9/11
[Music]
don't even say 9/11 that horrific event
in ever since then you gotta have your
[ __ ] passport to go everywhere so I
checked like [ __ ] 900 times make sure
I have my passport and I went through
the customs and everything I think I got
there at like four o'clock and then like
the pickup was like at 5:15 so by the
time I got through customs and all of
that [ __ ] ordered room service and
everything like I barely had time to
iron my stupid shirt and then I went
over there and I did the whole you know
the whole red carpet got asked great
questions nobody tried to corner me you
know there was a couple of how would you
relate this movie to what's going on
today in the current political climate
you know was fine there was no way what
do you think about this guy going back
onstage I already knew what I was gonna
say well what do you think about it
that's all I ever do
you asked me one of those and your
career questions I just throw it right
back at you what do you think about it
no I'm asking you well I didn't ask the
question you're the one who has the
question you're the one thinking about
it what do you think about it but I want
to hear why wouldn't you put a quote on
it what do you think about it there they
are [ __ ] Jimmy Olsen so then we I
went into the this beautiful theater and
sat down and watched the movie and I
gotta tell you man it's pretty [ __ ]
incredible jason reitman killed it it's
called the front runner and I would not
be I don't want to jinx Eddy a.m. I
couldn't Jake's nothing but I would not
be surprised
I'll go real I'm gonna really go low
here the if it performs very well
th-that's that's as much [ __ ] as I'm
gonna talk but it's a phenomenal
phenomenal movie and the way the whole
thing was cut together the way they told
the story and it's really really
fascinating it's about the the Gary Hart
story which for you youngsters out there
he was a guy running for president in
1988 and yes he was the front-runner
great looking guy guys like them ladies
loved them full head of hair you know
that's the kind of [ __ ] that gets you
elected right play the saxophone on our
City Hall to terms not one two terms
[ __ ] that they just hit a [ __ ]
homerun guy that was a monster shot five
to two the Astros no quittin um you know
why cuz they're champions
oh man that's that [ __ ] guy what is
his name that's the guy last year in the
World Series that was incredible
you know the dude that I let was Altuve
right that guy that guy's works every
time you pay him you know outside like I
like that guy in the infield for the
Texas Rangers total winner the guy who
punched that dude in the face credible
ball player that's gonna be a shame
watching the Red Sox the Yankees buy him
away from the Rangers although back in
the day the Rangers spent all that money
on a rod right 220 million bucks so they
got money
that's Texas man you sitting on all that
[ __ ] oil why don't you take some of
that money put it on your team anyway so
I got there went thank God everything I
got there on time and I got to see
movies phenomenal everybody in it he's
so [ __ ] good I'm not gonna lie to you
I had my head down whenever here my boys
put my head down but uh
you know I watched I actually watched
most my scenes and I wasn't cringing too
badly so I think I think I did all right
in it but I want to thank everybody for
everyone I worked with and giving me the
opportunity to be in it but I think it's
gonna be a great one so guys could you
do me a favor I know you're all
streaming [ __ ] I know you got your
[ __ ] virtual reality glasses with
your laser disc players whatever the
[ __ ] you kids are doing nowadays could
you just go old-school just go to the
movies when it comes up just go see this
thing all right do it for me do it for
me so one day I can afford to buy
speaker wires that actually are
microphone wires that actually work okay
it's for a cause this is a startup I
think it comes out in November
go see it you will not be disappointed
there that's it all right
plowing ahead oh look a rod a rods in
the [ __ ] box that there's another guy
another guy Tony Romo and Alex Rodriguez
I say whether the two best former
athletes turned broadcasters in a long
goddamn time
it's unreal how when a-rod was a player
and in the New York media would be
asking him all those questions he'd get
like tongue-tied you get him in the
booth he's just he's effortless [ __ ]
effortless all right speaking of
effortless not effortless I should say I
got to do some reads here for the week I
forgot to turn the goddamn light on so
anyways and then this morning I had a
6:00 a.m. 6:00 a.m. flight but was
awesome there was nobody in Toronto I've
gotten some of the worst traffic other
than LA in Chicago and some of those
other [ __ ] places Toronto is just
brutal traffic and I woke up this
morning and there was nothing nobody out
there on a Sunday morning
and uh went right through customs thing
of beauty and then I went to go buy some
[ __ ] Cuban cigars there and that
prices were out [ __ ] rageous dude I
was looking at I was looking at a box of
them they won like five hundred and
sixty bucks it's like dude I can get
these things and I know people in LA got
these things not paying all that money
so end up buying that these these with
these little ones about like five I mean
what the hell you call [ __ ] now they
[ __ ] hitting us now they're hitting
us how many outs how many outs here it's
the top of the six and game you guys
already know the results of it's five to
two this has never been good other than
the fact that one time when that guy ran
the ball back to win the game that was
the only time this was a good move to
have the [ __ ] game on all right let
me read some of the alright let me read
some of the advertising here for Oh my
book everybody you know ever since I
started this podcast people have been
asking me for advice ask me what team to
bet on I don't know if you ever asked me
that you guys did ask me back in the day
who I like to if I was going win the
Super Bowl the truth is I don't know
who's gonna win but if you think you
know you gotta check out my bookie
remember who you're bettin on is just as
important as who you're betting with
that's why you need to go to my bookie
trust them according to them they're
your best bet this season they've been
in business for you
they have great reviews online and their
mobile site is easy to you I would I
would love to read reviews of gambling
sites my wife left me [ __ ] is sat I
would only recommend a service to my
listeners that's been good to me the you
guys my book you have to change this
[ __ ] copy okay I don't gamble alright
well I mean I I gamble with my friends I
don't go to a site here okay you've been
good to me in that you're paying me
money to read this [ __ ] but I mean I I
haven't done anything with you guys okay
anyways that's why evidently I'm urging
you to make your way to my bookie you
win
they pay it's how it works they have in
game live betting the most rewarding
player perks in the business and you for
you fantasy guys out there I like this
[ __ ] here you can even bet the
over-under on how many fantasy points a
player will score each game join now and
my bookie will match your deposit
dollar-for-dollar i like betting on
stupid [ __ ] coin tosses you don't I mean
that's like the appetizers to like your
real bet you know what I mean just to
keep you [ __ ] going anyways use the
promo code Burpee URR to activate the
offer visit my bookie online today
that's my bookie my Bo ok ie and don't
forget to use the promo code bar when
creating your account to claim up to one
thousand dollars in free play you play
you win you get paid or you lose and you
don't get laid you know what I realized
is that I bought this this [ __ ]
microphone wire headphone [ __ ] all of
this stuff and it's so heavy that it was
hanging off the table that's why
everything actually works
once again I [ __ ] flip out and there
was a simple solution and there was no
reason to have a meltdown I do it all
the time ok so now they got [ __ ] two
guys on base nobody out we got a Radian
a lefty warming up in the bullpen this
is why the Astros won it last year
you cannot put these guys to bed you
can't tuck them in all right policy
genius September is National Life
Insurance Awareness Month most people
aren't aware of that in fact most people
aren't aware they need well most people
aren't [ __ ] away the light turn green
too busy staring at that goddamn phones
in fact most people aren't aware they
need life insurance at all that's why
40% of people don't have it well I mean
something they're not aware it's a lot
of it is guys and we don't like dealing
with our mortality but I did it I have
my affairs in order and I cannot tell
you as a husband and a father knowing
that when I croak everybody that I love
in my family is gonna be ok it's great
then you can have like a happy funeral
you know people show up in brand-new
black clothing anyways but getting life
insurance doesn't need to be difficult
or expensive right now prices are the
lowest they've been in 20 years
why is that it's because people are
living longer and policy genius has made
it easier than ever to get covered
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they cover it so if
you're looking for a good reason to buy
life insurance here's three it's
national life insurance awareness month
that's not a good reason okay could be
national get a hooker month doesn't mean
you should go do it right so that one's
out prices are at a 20-year low that's a
good one and policy genius makes it easy
to get the right policy for you
wait they said there was three reasons
it's national life insurance awareness
month prices are a 20-year low oh and
then the rest is policy genius makes it
easy to get the right policy for you
there you go go to policy genius.com get
quotes and apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing on your phone right now
policy genius for all you dummies like
me pol I see why ge and I u.s. the
easiest way to could way to compare and
buy life insurance genius is not an easy
word to spell it's an easy one to [ __ ]
up like restaurant that's an easy one
anyways draftkings it's week two of the
football season is it well I guess
because it's yeah cuz I'm supposed to be
reading this tomorrow but there's still
Monday night anyways which means a
second shot at victory bragging rights
and huge cast prizes are up for grabs
all season long at draftkings the lady
in one week's fantasy sports this
weekend draftkings has over two million
dollars in total prizes and you can play
for free with your first deposit to
compete for your share with one week
fantasy at draftkings you choose when to
play draft a new team every week with no
see
long commitment at draftkings you are
the GM just choose your players stay
under the salary cap and see how you how
your team stacks up against the
competition no matter what your skill
level that's so fascinating now you know
they got like the De Niro character
handicap and each team I every know the
salary cap has to be different for every
team right did they do that that would
be [ __ ] incredible if they did that
nay they picked that you know they
picked that perfect [ __ ] number so
you can't quite get all the guys you
want that's where this skill comes in
anyways no matter what your skill level
is there's a contest waiting for you at
drafting so if you've been waiting up
been thinking about trying one week
fantasy football now is the time to play
because nothing makes football Sunday
more exciting than when you put your
hope that when you bet responsibly that
when you have a draftkings line up on
the line
download the app or go to draftkings.com
now use promo code Burpee you are are to
enter a contest for free this weekend
with your first deposit and compete for
your share of over two million dollars
in total prizes
that's code Burpee you are are at only a
trafficking's
Jesus the game inside the game minimum
five dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings.com
for details you know what I really miss
I miss football cards that's how I knew
who everybody was in the league I
[ __ ] miss those things
and what happens was all those [ __ ]
baseball cards from the 1950s all the
Mickey Mantle rookie cards and all of
that [ __ ] blew up and were with all that
money so by the time I became an adult
so many adults were collecting cards
kids didn't give a [ __ ] about it and
then I tried collecting football cards
again and they they would like to
liberally make some of them rare you
couldn't just go out and go buy a whole
set because that's what people were
doing and then they weren't [ __ ]
worth anything
let me see tops let me see that they
still have these things football card
2018 2018 what do you got here buddy
will my internet work you know what I
don't even care if it does it it does or
doesn't I'm not gonna flip out about it
how about that
just relax bill just count to 10 slowly
what you know I got a master I got a
master going for a walk the other day I
got into with my wife right and and I
started to walk away but I didn't leave
you know all right shop tops football
cards 2018 football cards release dates
all right let's see what they got here
it's such a good feeling I used to just
sit there and like I wouldn't study in
school and I would just look at football
cards and I would read I would look at
the picture and I would just read them
over and over and over again I didn't
realize it was like flashcards and by
the end of it I knew everybody in the
league I knew where they went to cook is
it I would watch it every year I get the
cards every year and there was all these
guys that I already knew [ __ ] about and
there was only so many new rookies and
memory used to blow my dad's mind LA and
he went to college if he can't stay
Louie Cal just as a size 16 quadruple
East cleat he like Jesus Christ how do
you know all of this stuff bill well dad
cuz I'm not studying all that effort
that I should have put in to my studies
so I could have gone to a big-time
college you know and joined a frat
walked around you know maybe joined the
glee club or whatever I've had an
acapella group you know met some women
get me two [ __ ] years later I just
missed out on it when the [ __ ] is this
thing gonna load all right you know I'm
just gonna start reading some questions
maybe there's at some point I don't know
for life me I don't know how much money
I have to pay these internet guys to get
something that works you know I was
started to talk about this where a buddy
of mine
had you know he solved this internet
problem buddy they got these things
called like mesh or something like that
where it ties the internet signal from
one part of your house to another and
that just seems like you are in the TSA
line for [ __ ] brain cancer like it's
bad enough we got all these with it
can't be good
I don't know what it is but there's
something going on we've all done it
we've all talked on a cell phone long
enough that like the psy.d you [ __ ]
one side of your head starts feeling
weird you know what I mean I just do a
bit about that so then you talk with the
cell phone the other side of your head
sort of Seir it like a [ __ ] tuna
steak it's just your brain all right
Eastern European tour hello bill I am
writing from Croatia I like to ask you
if you are still coming to this part of
the world my part of the world not yours
just kidding yes I am we're just working
it out because the dates came in and I
was going to be gone for too long I have
a kid so I'm trying to break it up into
two different tours due a week to 10
days and then come back a few months
later and do another week to 10 today
ten ten days ten two days ten days
that's what I'm trying to do okay I
promise you it is going to happen all
right
outdoor venues uh oh I did one this
weekend so I am ready I'm ready for this
question dear Billy Operation Northwoods
look it up all right well my internet
work sir I would love to look it up it's
still loading all right
thanks for the killer show in the casino
parking lot oh thank you for showing up
anyways he said I've heard you mention a
guy named lawhead before but I never
knew [ __ ] about him [ __ ] hilarious
guy yeah jail or had jail aw come on man
that guy [ __ ] kills it on the grill
to follow him on Instagram you see that
guy when that guy starts cooking it's
[ __ ] crazy it's like a cooking show
uh how come he's not on netflix or
see-saw I think it's C so or whatever
the [ __ ] you guys do anyways wondering
if the parking lot is up there in the
weirdest outdoor venues you've played at
all right why isn't Jay on Netflix well
or C so went out of business what else
is there Hulu Amazon and all that well
eventually it happens for everybody
everybody you know it takes people
different amount of time you know look I
started in 1992 and it took me until
either 2005 or 2006 to get on Letterman
and I went through a couple of Booker's
a couple that was just like yeah I don't
like you or you got a weird we got a
weird look is one that I got I don't
think that was some Letterman people but
yeah you know is hilarious remember
years later seeing this other
generations of comedians and they were
like bitching about the book booking
process and they were like seven years
in it's just like whoa hey [ __ ]
buckle up buddy it's gonna take you
another yeah I don't but that's not how
it works it's not how it works nowadays
because now there's social media cuz now
you [ __ ] complain and then
everybody's afraid to get in trouble and
nobody no he just goes okay you don't
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] score two runs go oh my
god
these [ __ ] Houston Astros are
relentless look at them they're all up
there top of the day this is impressive
this is what we've been doing the team's
all year and now they're coming and
giving us the old right there Fred [ __ ]
I already know what they're saying with
the sound down that ball got up there in
the zone I mean that thing you want that
much lower this is like that's right in
his wheelhouse and he jumped all over
his eyes they they'll open up like a kid
on Christmas [ __ ] me
anyways I love that you guys know the
result of this Houston chance so I was
talking all that [ __ ] like we're gonna
whip y'all [ __ ] city's ass today
if there is a sports god just because
that woman is wearing that giant stupid
[ __ ] hat in in a visitor's Stadium
you know I mean just how many times can
you just
to get your [ __ ] ass kicked before it
happens anyways yeah so people like ya
then
started whining about I don't know how
long it takes or whatever and then I
guess it's shortened up it's so [ __ ]
stupid
it's particularly hard for me it's like
what are you what are you seeing out
there like here's the deal it might be
more difficult for you but nobody has it
easy [ __ ] sitting there acting like
goddamn [ __ ] Spielberg sends me a
[ __ ] sandwich every day which would
be nice if he's listening every once in
a while alright outdoor venues yes
where's the weirdest venues that I
played outdoor venues that I played it I
used to open up for what Wynonna Judd
way back in the day and we we did a lot
of outdoor venues you know when you sell
in that level of tickets she basically
was selling so many tickets that they
didn't have an indoor venue big enough
so you have to you have to go outside at
some point so I open it up up for her at
the I believe it's the Del Mar racetrack
I thought I told this story so I go down
there and it's one of these deals with
it like hey you know work clean this is
a country crowd these people uh they
don't like carsick which you know you
have to respect it's not my crowd I'm
opening for this person this is what
they've created you know for all you
young comics out there to then go up
there and and in curse anyways is that's
not a Lenny Bruce moment that you're
you're acting like a jerk-off because
they probably told you before they even
got the gig you got to work clean so if
you're not gonna work clean don't take
the gig but don't say you're gonna work
clean and then go up there and start
talking about your nuts or more
accurately these days your [ __ ] [ __ ]
because female comics are that [ __ ]
dick Joe comics of today
some of the [ __ ] filth that I I mean
some of the bits it's just like I
remember this bit except there were dick
and balls and I was standing in a bar
trying to figure out how the [ __ ] am I
gonna follow this [ __ ] anyway so I had
to work clean it was during the day
which actually didn't bug me cuz I was
psyched cuz I was making money I always
loved like those gigs like a lot of
times the nooners and [ __ ] sucked but
what was awesome was when it was over
you had you check and you already make
money and you could maybe double up and
do another gig or you were like done at
like a normal hour so um well I never
happened you know you always went out
and did more [ __ ] time what we gonna
do sit at home be alone with your
thoughts so I went down there and y know
it was always like really nice to me and
I went down to open up so now I got to
work clean it's outside I'm in the Sun
I'm a redhead I still had my hair back
then so I didn't need a hat and I'm up
there and I'm doing my [ __ ] and all of a
sudden this lady in the crowd who I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say was a
lesbian you know she had that haircut
the whole [ __ ] thing I know you know
it you're not supposed to do at least
you're not supposed to do that with
lesbians you know you could do that with
other groups of people you know don't be
a Brad don't be a Chad you can [ __ ]
do that but if you go the other way all
of a sudden you're an [ __ ] but yeah I
mean if I had to put my life savings on
it and the same people that were
criticizing me if it was a life or death
situation if you had to put money on it
you would say this was a lesbian right
why is it pertinent to the story cuz I'm
painting a picture alright
and all you liberal [ __ ] out there
acting like you don't have a [ __ ]
idea in your head when I say that that
she was a lesbian you have no no [ __ ]
idea what I'm saying what if I said it
was a frat boy you got you boom you got
to get that picture in your head right
anyway so she sit there
and I'm on stage and she sit the whole
like I maybe get three minutes into my
act
well [ __ ] outside it's brutal and
she's just standing she's that's going
and she's trying to get the rest of the
crowd to do it with her which they're
not thankfully but she's [ __ ]
relentless and I don't know if I did a
joke that she didn't like or maybe it
was that I had a dick I have no [ __ ]
idea well maybe I was just on pace to
you maybe she thought I was weird
looking well maybe she was just a [ __ ] I
have no idea but she's doing that and
I'm sitting there and I want to go off
on her but I got to work clean so I
actually just stopped and I gathered
myself and I said ain't lady I was like
what is the problem why are you chanting
why not why don't it why no not she's
gonna come out here at 8:30 no matter
what she's coming out at 8:30 okay do
you think I I thought all you guys came
out here to see me
I know why I'm here I'm dancing monkey
boy but blah blah blah blah blah and I
got the crowd on my side and then I made
fun of her haircut I had to I had to do
it because I had to make sure I got all
the Trump supporters on my side I was
flailing and then I got him and I
started to having getting laughs and
that lady was pissed and she was still
chant why no no but now is drowning her
out with laughs and I was winning a
redhead in the Sun with his pasty
freckled back up against a non-existent
wall was turning it around and then out
of nowhere the crown went from laughing
I don't know where they just went all at
the same time and I couldn't figure out
what the [ __ ] happened I thought my fly
came down I had no idea and I turned
around and behind me was a way off in
the distance was a carnival and there's
some ride where they just shoot you up
in the [ __ ] air like like Superman so
I'm standing there [ __ ] finally
getting the crowd and right is this
starting to pay attention to me in the
way in the background some guy got shot
up in the [ __ ] air on this ride and
then I kind of made fun of that I'm not
another hit Oh another hit another run
scores and we got ourselves a tie game
five to five just like that
coach is coming out to the mound Jesus
Christ Wow and we're deep into our
[ __ ] bullpen already this is not
looking good guys anyways so yeah that
was a weird one I've done also I've done
college gigs in a sort of that area you
know the walk of shame area between
dorms I've done that and there was also
like sort of a carnival thing set up
there was always a [ __ ] cut it was
always rides some sort of popcorn
machine I remember a long time ago this
one was actually inside it was me
Patrice O'Neal Robert Kelly Dane Cook
and al del bene we're all doing this gig
it was something some sort of Jewish
thing I don't remember what it was a
function hall and the crowd which was
predominantly Jewish I don't it couldn't
have been [ __ ] they don't go to
church where they go to Temple that
could have been related to that I they
wouldn't hired us I don't know what it
was well I know is we were up there and
none of us were in the business long
enough to recognize like that we were
going why is this microphone so small
like you could hold it with just your
two fingers I remember Al went up there
first going this is the smallest
microphone I've ever seen and then he
put it in his mouth and started humming
or whatever and people laughed I was
like oh my god I got a
hold that thing now I got to go up after
him right so we did the whole we did the
whole [ __ ] show
I remember when Patrice got up there he
was holding it with his big [ __ ] fat
fingers just holding this little thing
in his three things like he was holding
a teacup and it wasn't until years later
when I did my first TV gig that I
realized it was a lapel mic and none of
us knew to just clip it on your shirt
and then just walk around like you're
doing the one-man show you know with
both hands so we uh we would like finish
our act and there was a mic stand and we
would like drape it over and then the
next guy would come up and just pick it
up with his index finger and his thumb
yeah I don't know I'm gonna be honest
with you all of those hell gigs they all
just kinda kind of fade away after a
while I can't I don't remember I just
know I've had a bunch of [ __ ] thrown at
me I think I just after a while you just
you don't want to remember him yeah I
don't know I I've done some I've
definitely done some weird well I know
I've done all right didn't went outside
I'm on the [ __ ] Westside Highway
there was like boats and [ __ ] and all
these [ __ ] flies and stuff yeah these
are all starting to come back home it
was hot as [ __ ] to and I was up then I
had like a long-sleeve button down cuz I
just worked like a comedy club so they
had like the air conditioning cranking
and then I went over and did that gig
and I was like sweating my ass up yeah
I've done I've done a lot of those
that's kind of par for the course that
happens that was a fun one though I open
for Wynonna outside and up in a in a
parking lot parking lot racetrack the
occasional theater I opened up for in a
parking lot in Laughlin Nevada Jesus -
why you bringing back all of these
memories alright
smoothie dear bill years and years back
you said Kevin James told you the
benefits of having liquid first in the
morning to get your engine going Kevin
James I don't have to get the name right
I've only met him like once a smoothie
water etc then a few years ago you
basically
[ __ ] that because you thought it was too
much it might have read it was bad for
you now you're doing smoothies do you
think it'll stick this time no pun
intended
go blend yourself well I didn't know how
to make one healthy back then you don't
I mean there's a lot of them it's just
like you do all this stuff and there's a
bunch of sugar and [ __ ] that you're
putting in there now that I've been
using like unsweetened almond milk or
almond milk I used to hate it now I'm
kind of used to it I got a good one for
you one cup of almond milk a little um
miming doing this putting the [ __ ] in
then it's like a teaspoon of cinnamon a
frozen banana two tablespoons of almond
peanut butter a tablespoon of maca
powder and some ice a little bit of ice
you blend that [ __ ] together it's
delicious tastes like a goddamn
chocolate shake and you drink it and you
have energy for hours I gotta be I gotta
be honest with you if I actually knew
enough about nutrition and all I could
do if all I could do is just that and
just do a liquid diet I would love to do
that I would absolutely love to do that
there's another one I have that's like
kale
it says apple juice that's the only I
don't like it's apple juice and just
apple juice has a bunch of sugar in so I
went to like this [ __ ] hilarious this
health food store
but like they don't like gays [ __ ] I was
like how did those things go together
it's usually like hey man here's some
vitamins and everybody's like everybody
man who the [ __ ] would whoever saw that
coming so yeah I would love to do that
like dude if you saw some of this [ __ ]
that I'm [ __ ] eating there look at
this [ __ ] I miss Boston just saw a
guy he had a Red Sox like knitted cap on
with a Tom Brady Jersey and a
of sitting right along the third-base
line [ __ ] hilarious I I would love to
do that
I like vegetarian and vegan meals but I
also still like steak but I know if I
combine like all of that [ __ ] I can
still eat a little bit like John Wayne
and not have a problem
alright you disrespected Miles Davis you
[ __ ]
alright what is this hey Bill in season
2 episode 4 of f is for family there is
an album cover parroting the Miles Davis
kind of blue in the background of one
scene in the corner of the cover there
appears to be a label of Blue Note
Records in this case black Note Records
these two instances of factual are
factually incorrect dude how much do you
[ __ ] jazz guys you know back in the
[ __ ] day I used to host this show
called the jazz Oasis on the [ __ ] was it
88.9 wer s at Emerson College and I used
to finite and no [ __ ] anything about
jazz and I'd ask you [ __ ] [ __ ] to
call in requests and none of you
[ __ ] would call in all you
would do is wait for me to play a record
and then all you [ __ ] [ __ ] would get
on the phone and call me I'll be like
[ __ ] you playing that for man that ain't
jazz the [ __ ] is that did a jazz
[ __ ] all you [ __ ] guys can go
[ __ ] yourselves go sit on your [ __ ]
horn alright first of all did you enjoy
the show did you enjoy the episode
listen to this ass those are factually
incorrect kind of blue was released
released on Columbia Records
nobody likes labels record labels more
than these [ __ ] jazz people and Miles
Davis at the time had not recorded for
Blue Note in a number of years you might
want to get your facts straight you
believe this [ __ ] if you want to
reference the greatest jazz record of
all time it may behoove you to respect
possibly the greatest musician of the
20th century by simply getting some sim
factual information correct on your show
you dumb [ __ ] Tony Williams is probably
ashamed of you let's be honest all right
sir I'm gonna walk you back through all
your [ __ ] okay first of all the
reason why it didn't say Blue Note or
Columbia Records is because we would
have had that we would had to get
permission to do that that's also the
reason why the song kind of sounded like
kind of blue but wasn't because we don't
have the [ __ ] budget to use that
music all right that's why that's why it
looked like that okay and then secondly
Tony Williams didn't play on that record
you dumb [ __ ] I can for the record I
thought it was Philly Joe Jones I looked
it up it was like some guy Jimmy Cobb or
something I hope I got his [ __ ] name
wrong just he can blow another gasket
[ __ ] all you jazz guys you stupid [ __ ]
you're not you're not making an animated
show you have no [ __ ] idea how much
money music costs that's why we did that
okay and what we weren't disrespecting
Miles Davis okay so why don't you take
all your words like behoove stick them
in your clarinet and shove it up your
ass you pretentious [ __ ] [ __ ]
good he didn't even get the right
drummer after giving me [ __ ] he didn't
get the right [ __ ] drummer Tony
Williams is part of his second great
quintet I do know that I but I don't I
don't know [ __ ] about jazz but I do know
that the reason why we did that was
because it would we Columbia Records and
blue no probably wanted to given his
permission and if they did it would have
cost us more money than it costs to
[ __ ] make the whole season and we
would have been screwed
that's why sir okay so we didn't
disrespect him we tipped our [ __ ] cap
tool by the way do you play any
instrument are you in a band now right
anger issue ha ha ha ha this could not
come at a better time
anger issues uh anger issues if we don't
get out of this [ __ ] any oh we did we
finally got out of the inning
dear Billy red-top dear bill bill red
top okay I had anger issues when I was
younger oh my god is this gonna be a
rail light I had a good family but I
grew up in a neighborhood that exposed
me to [ __ ] I shouldn't have seen as a
defense
I started reacting to everything with
anger and it carried on into my adult
life did I write this in a drunken state
and I forgot because this sounds like me
I've read lots of books and even wrote a
few unpublished ones on the topic myself
see you actually worked on it I commend
you for that I just like try for a few
days and then I just go back to what I
know anyways it kept me from being the
happiest I could be it didn't ruin my
life but it's kept me from enjoying
things I had a bad habit of looking at
people who were happy and finding
reasons not to like them I don't do that
I think I did that my 20s but I'm not
like that even people I was close to
which may sound strange no I did that a
long time ago and then I've also had
that done to me I remember when I bought
my old truck 68 f100 short bed this guy
was like what you get a truck huh hey
you gonna put stuff back there just like
annoyed because everybody was looking at
my truck going dude that thing is so
[ __ ] badass
nobody has that out here this thing's
the [ __ ] you know anyways I've been
catching up on your podcast over the
last year and I've heard you go from
being much very angry to still pretty
being pretty angry but certainly less
angry than before I'm glad you've made
strides well not on this podcast because
I can tell you the most important thing
I gained from reprogramming my immediate
reaction to everything from anger to
observance is time I'm not smart enough
to only read that sentence once I got to
do this again I can tell you the most
important thing I gained from rechromed
reprogramming my immediate reaction to
everything from anger to observance is
time what does that mean you got
back or something or you you're enjoying
your life more because you have to spend
so much of it apologizing for what you
did an hour ago anyway it's it's sneaky
though being angry can waste a whole day
and you can do things while still being
agitated but you don't feel like you're
completely unaccounted for a whole day I
just do it like in spurts then it goes
all the way up to the top then it come
back down alright cuz what the hell's
wrong with you yeah you're right I'm
sorry you know I'm just trying to think
about what you still ran your your
errands who did your jobs and fed your
kid etc but you probably ignoring things
you could be doing to advance yourself
you're likely not appreciating those who
are we talking about here is this me
am I getting a stern talking-to or are
you just a hypothetical you but you're
probably ignoring things you could be
doing to advance yourself you're likely
not appreciating those around you who
make your life good because you are
focused on people who make your life
terrible or projecting things on people
that aren't there I don't do any of that
with anybody in my life I do that with
the people that are in power I do that a
lot you know like I was all ready to
[ __ ] talk about everybody at Best Buy
like this is like two podcasts in a row
and they've done nothing wrong it's just
been me needing to make a couple
adjustments anyways my biggest regret in
all my anger years was snapping at
people who were genuinely good people
who didn't have that angry gene it's
like being six foot one two fifty and
kicking the hell out of a small kid they
can't defend themselves because if they
do they become the maniac you are
horrible position to put someone in hope
you crossed the finish line to Zen yeah
I mean I think I'm somewhere in the
middle of angry and Zen believe it or
not as much as I flip out like I was I
was a lot worse but uh I don't wish bad
[ __ ] on people and I don't resent
anybody I don't I
just it's you know what things things
make me freak out anything
technology-related
makes me flip up but you know what's
funny is if I get something old I have
all the patience in the world you know
like if my old truck won't start I
actually you know I mean I'm not gonna
say I enjoy it but I find it the process
of figuring out what's wrong with it
enjoyable and then learning you know as
the truck gets fixed what that was why
that happened how to prevent it in the
future
oh yeah I tell you this you know what
playing drums really helped me get back
into playing drums and you know meet Nia
having a kid just [ __ ] that made me
happy has kind of gotten me to that but
my big thing is if I could just stop
snapping that's kind of what I don't
walk it like you know it's funny these
people actually think I am like an angry
guy like I walk around angry I don't I
just snap
I'm definitely loud and I'm definitely
[ __ ] crazy but I don't know maybe
I'll let you guys be I don't classify
myself as an angry guy I think I'm
talking about my drinking like I don't
think I'm an alcoholic I don't think I'm
an angry guy and I also think that I can
admit when I'm wrong I'll [ __ ] mess
all right dilemmas dilemma clarification
number one bill last week you read my
dilemma wrong
oh sorry jeez everybody coming at me you
have to either score perfectly on the
SATs with up to a year of studying or in
one sitting
win a game of Monopoly oh oh oh in one
city that means bankrupting all the
other players which one to save your
life all the [ __ ] SATs absolutely
those things are pretty hard but [ __ ]
winning monopoly in one sitting I mean
that's just I'd rather like sit down and
like this time around
really pay attention in math class and
and find out what I'm what this math is
she is applied to as opposed to just
being regurgitated at me then sitting
down and rolling dice like I'm in a
[ __ ] casino you know I mean Jesus
Christ can you imagine you know your
life's on the line and you're moving a
little dog or a shoe around a board I
think I would much rather leave it up to
my brain sort of a damned if you do
damned if you don't come on get
underneath that all right you ain't get
a challenge his arm okay okay
man on second top of the seventh one out
okay dear bill dear dear bill to thought
I have a dilemma for you would you
rather have to fight an alligator in a
water tank with a 12-inch blade or fight
an alligator in a room with the 30 inch
aluminum baseball bat alright well we
haven't talked about the size of the
alligator I'm assuming it's big enough
to kill me obviously well I remember a
long time ago a cop told me if you're
not gonna get a gun to get a bat because
you want to have distance between you
and the intruder so considering that the
intruder is a [ __ ] reptile passed
ball he goes to third [ __ ] I would yeah
I take the the baseball bat and the
weird thing about an alligator is you
got to come at him straight on right or
from behind but those [ __ ] things you
don't want to be on the side they bite
from the side if you're right in front
of them
you're all good that's why almost those
[ __ ] morons that go up and they stick
their their their arm in the guy's mouth
you gotta no [ __ ] way
holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] play that was
dude lay down the bunt that Altuve guy
came in who the [ __ ] was that Xander
Bogaerts who threw that [ __ ] ball who
true that ball I wasn't who he swang
actually actually wasn't a good throw he
got him throw was high he slid wide oh
no they're gonna reverse that ladies and
gentlemen ah you [ __ ]
that's gonna be that's he's safe anyways
yeah I would I would thirty inch
aluminum bat wait yeah wait wait a
minute that's not that big it's only
three feet all right this is us is so
weird
I would attack the top of his head from
behind but I'd start with his feet well
you know that would actually [ __ ]
kill me to do that to a living thing
like that I'd have to [ __ ] slowly
chop it down I attack the [ __ ] things
feet although I did see that one with
that [ __ ] on Rogen showed that with that
alligator bit the other ones leg and
just did the death roll rip the [ __ ]
things leg off and the other one wasn't
going like that was just going like
that's it
just [ __ ] done it barely bled so yeah
I think I think you just got to uh I
mean what I really love to do is just
sort of somehow getting on its back rub
its belly oh I know what I would do I'd
take my shirt off and I cover its eyes
I've seen those guys do that and then I
would take that [ __ ] bat and I would
just wham right down on its [ __ ] you
know I you know that would be it I
wouldn't want to kill an alligator I am
terrified of those things but I don't
live in the same world it does but if it
was me a him I mean that thing has to go
I've eaten alligator though night
alligator when I was in Florida it was
[ __ ]
just too goddamn gamy people like yeah
you know it tastes like chicken it
doesn't it doesn't chicken is [ __ ]
delicious steers are delicious those are
the pigs are delicious those are the
three [ __ ] best tasting things
turkeys are good they dry out though you
know that's why I think like if you get
to the upper level of you know if you
have a smoker if you actually know how
to smoke turkey how the [ __ ] did I do an
hour in 20 minutes all right that's the
podcast I have really appreciate people
that trying to help me with my temper
because I would like I mean I I need to
learn to like how to stop [ __ ]
snapping that's the big thing you know
I'm not gonna lie to you I do ramp it up
a little bit when I'm on the podcast
just to entertain you guys but that is
that was pretty legit earlier in this
show all right that's the podcast here
I'll check in on you on on Thursday go
[ __ ] yourselves
and I have a wonderful couple of days